[Music]
so I'm sure you made some progress but
maybe you fell off the horse and I want
you to keep coming back to this because
it's so important
so start forwards together remember what
you want to be able to do is reverse the
right then ultimately reverse the left
they're both going backwards reverse the
right reverse the left back to where you
started until you can just cycle through
that with some rhythm right reverses
left reverses right reverses that
reverses right versus left reverses
right reverses left reverses so if
that's not smooth remember keep building
enough learn to just reverse to the
right then just reverse the left then
with the left spinning make sure you can
Sweeney the right and then with the
right spinning make sure you can swing
your left and then make sure you can
with the right spinning you can swing
the left in the opposites and then get
it spinning and then with the right
swing make sure you can swing it up into
opposites and then start the whole thing
both spinning forwards right reverses
swings and the opposites and then at
first come back to where you started
then the left does both reverse the
nervous again and then you're ready
right reverses
left reverses right reverses left
reverses and you want to get to the
point where you can start kind of
bopping around and just relaxing or you
can put your music on
and you can just be really casual and
just it doesn't feel like no big thing
anymore and that's only gonna happen if
you play with it but trust me if you
play with it it's really gonna come I
haven't seen anybody not be able to get
this yet if they put in a little bit of
time right there versus that reverses
right versus left and right and right
and that's it
we're gonna come back to this and we're
going to go further with it but I need
you to start by really dialing that in
so this is your second chance practice
it and we'll go further